seals are here so I mean how waterlog do
you guys at the end of every day I mean
how much time you got spending water
we're not always in the water and land
seeing air landed more land and water
right missile welcome people what can
people expect from this show I mean
seals are something that are
action-packed and you always seen in the
movies but you don't see a lot of
portrayed on television show ask that
again I say no seals you know are
something that's action-packed you don't
see a lot of portrayal of seals on
television shows it's typically in
movies you see special apps so what can
we expect from the show this is the
first TV show that I'm aware of that has
all tier one operators and so I think
that it's going to be nice to see what
the top top elite teams are doing and
also telling their stories like we are
mission based on our show but we're also
really talking about the human beings
behind that they're complicated family
lives and and the relationships between
us and the Sun that has had I mean I
think there's really a seriousness that
you think of when you think about these
guys and it can see me dark but there's
a lot of fun that's a tune what was the
training like going into this I have you
know listen these guys that we're all I
mean mentally physically got to be in
shape I play ice hockey let's just shout
out to eat you Canada the Canadian boys
on the ice anytime you'd like to go I'm
ready so I'm an ice hockey player so I
literally play a lot ice hockey I mean
that's what I covered but there's
nothing that you can do that I civilians
could do to really think what they do is
not even intensive like what we were
trained for is not even a tenth of what
they do so you have to kind of be
prepared to be able to carry the ruck
sacks all day and we were doing that the
parachute scene the other day about 140
pounds of gear on for about five hours
with other seals that were there and
they're like such Java we're sweat
you're wearing real geared up you know
because you move a certain way it's not
real like the director was very adamant
that we wear all the weight of what it
is no change it doesn't change the
movement yeah and twice about where you
sign up for no it is a dream roll man I
wouldn't change for anything this is
awesome bring it I do by yourself
what are your parents think when you're
like hey mom now I'm going to play a
Navy SEAL
I'm not playing enable you're not but
you're the only one is not playing as
you I thought maybe she was playing a
feel we're in Canada we haven't seen it
yet
so what's the character you're playing
obvious obviously I play a CIA okay
operative analyst analyst group yes I
have the heavy lifting inside the
air-conditioned office I'm on a radio I
got a letter lingo better guys by it's a
super fun dynamic with this group and it
moves so quickly and the stakes are life
or death actually a lot of fun and what
do you guys most excited for fans to see
this season you love Dida
our hair muscle dog Zita she that's his
phone guns are bomb sniffer she's all
food in every week just for that just
for the dog
thanks very much guys